a source tells e.t torrey spelling and
dean mcdermott are quote struggling but
won't get a divorce anything that's
worth anything isn't easy something
that important you have to work on e.t
soar says the couple do things as a
family for the sake of their kids and
live in the same house but they sleep in
separate rooms quote tori is more vocal
about what goes on between them and dean
is just completely checked out you know
what right now my kids and dogs sleep in
my bag right back in june during an
appearance on jeff lewis live tori
opened up about why she and her husband
don't share a bed instead torrey says
some of their kiddos sleep with her she
was gone for six months filming in
another country they all stayed with me
so i currently still have four in the
bedroom with me who have yet to go back
to their rooms and they all sleep in bed
with you
uh they have beds in there okay and two
sleep in bed with me and four year
and pets and three dogs now e.t source
says they are quote very much struggling
quote dean has been caught in so many
lies and infidelities over the years and
tori is just over it dean does not want
to get divorced because of financial
reasons and tori doesn't want to for the
sake of their family tori's mom candy
also despises dean and it's a very
hostile and sad situation we've been
through a lot of course back in 2014
dean publicly admitted to cheating on
tori no i'm not a monster i'm a human
being and i messed up
i messed up and i'm owning up to it i'm
human you know i'm not i'm not the first
person to ever
cheat on his wife i won't be the last
um i'm human
you know i made a mistake
my
my personal
my life and how i was feeling about
myself was in a really bad place
you know the the affair was more about
how i was feeling about myself than
having an affair and following the
affair they documented their lives
together on their reality series true
tori where they spoke openly about
dean's transgressions
absolutely i cheated on my wife that's
my worst
nightmare or that you got caught
i don't know
but two years later in 2016 they told et
they were the best they had ever been in
our relationship we've definitely kind
of had to uh not start over but rebirth
the relationship as something that was
new and kind of moving on towards the
future and by doing that we've had this
like
great amazing like rebirth of our
relationship and it's just more exciting
each day in the best place it's it's
ever been for sure yeah i was just
thinking of how
grateful i am and how filled with
gratitude i am that we're still
together and my life is wonderful i have
these wonderful babies with you
i have this wonderful life with you i'm
just i'm so grateful and
happy
i think we've definitely
defied
what society has told us you know a
relationship should be monogamy should
be
this is what happens when indiscretion
happens and it can't go forward and you
know we've kind of thrown all that out
the window and just focused on each
other and what's grown is something that
has been even more amazing than either
of us thought could ever be fast forward
to 2021 and e.t source says the couple
is trying to figure out next steps and
adds attori isn't dating anyone else
last month the 90210 star was spotted
looking emotional during a heated phone
conversation outside of a lawyer's
office after reports surfaced that dean
had been flirting with other women
thinking a marriage is easy i don't know
it was very naive i guess
of us to think that and when it spoke to
tori back in august she opened up about
how she handles all the attention on her
marriage just have to let it go it's
going to be what it's going to be